wow siguiente decks bien hola mi nombre
es fabián estoy casado con rosana
tenemos tres hijos juntos hemos formado
una hermosa familia desde hace más de
veinte años que soy ingeniero trabajo en
universidad 11 enseña ingeniería dirijo
una facultad donde todos los donde se
enseña ingeniería y dirijo a donde los
estudiantes reciben todos los años
cientos de estudiantes enseño evalúas
futuros ingenieros los mismos que un
tiempo después les entregó su título
participó en distintos foros y jornadas
científicas donde analizamos sobre la
ingeniería y cómo mejorarla amo mi
profesión pero el camino para llegar
aquí no fue fácil hoy vengo a contarles
sobre ese camino que comienza una mañana
de 1979 cuando era un niño de 11 años un
niño que soñó un poco un niño que soñó
en grande
como podemos ver aquí esto es un ayer y
en lo que se puede ver lo que no se
puede ver
es el 75% de sauber y es aéreo
representa la meta alcanzada haber
llegado a ser ingeniero y lo asocio con
una otra imagen
qué es de haber llegado un pico a que en
el norte argentino muchos picos de
montaña para hacer y uno de mis sueños
era poder alcanzar uno de ellos pero
para ello tuve que entrenar tuve que
empezar a caminar luego tuve que correr
tuve que controlar mi oxígeno tuve que
controlar el agua cuando ascendí a la
montaña tenía calambres tuve que parar
muchas veces tuve que en longar tenía
previsto 6 horas más o menos de subir y
bajar y finalmente fueron 11 hora y
media y tuve que controlar un bien
escaso el agua tal cual como en mi vida
universitaria que era el dinero u otras
dificultades que tenía entonces asocio
eso porque porque en el camino para ser
ingeniero hay muchas dificultades quien
no tuvo un problema con un profesor
quien no tuvo un problema con una
materia que no me caía bien no generaba
empatía o todo lo contrario si un
profesor que se había muchísimo y sabía
transmitir y otro que sería muchísimo y
no sabía transmitir mucho y otro que más
o menos sabía pero tenía tanta pasión
cuando enseñaba que terminábamos todo
aprendiendo bien esa es la parte de la
que no se ve del aire y eso es lo que
vengo a comentarles en el día de hoy acá
lo que se ve en una cara feliz porque
alcance la meta pero nadie vio todo
y eso que tuve las veces que me caí para
poder ascender lo mismo que pasa cuando
uno busca una profesión
en mi caso de ingeniero que es esa parte
que no se ve como le iba diciendo empecé
una mañana de 1979 cuando era un niño
nosotros venimos de una familia muy
humilde
originalmente mi madre fue empleada
doméstica mi padre tenía trabajos
diferente hasta que entró a trabajar
como funcionario en empleado público y
así fue ellos fueron construyendo y
fueron tratando de salir de esa zona de
humildad bajo el recurso hace una franja
social un poquitito más alta y tenían la
idea y el sueño de que sus hijos se
pudieran recibir somos la primera
generación no nuestro hermano y nuestros
primos primera generación de
profesionales recibido en la universidad
y esta historia como digo empezó así una
mañana cuando yo me dirigía a la escuela
finalización del curso era el fin de
acto del primario estaba terminando me
encontré con la profesora con la maestra
de grado en la esquina de la plaza antes
de llegar a la escuela y me dice fabián
está con fiebre la abanderada vos que
sos escolta debes tomar la bandera pero
te pido regrese de regreso a tu casa
cambiarte to jim y cambiarte tus
zapatillas
y yo sabía que si volvía a mi casa no
tenía un mejor jean y zapatillas
estaba desgastado y nyse para ti ya
estaba abierta de punta en punta
entonces frente de la escuela hay una
plaza y digo 123 sin vuelta la verdad no
sé cuánta vuelta di porque yo tenía un
conmigo mismo algo que me decían iba a
deshonrar la bandera si entraba así pero
finalmente tomé coraje entre
portela bandera disfruté ese momento
salí fui feliz y me fui a dormir
contento y al otro día me levanté un
ganador total porque porque había tomado
la bandera conste que el abanderado y
ocasionalmente él había tenido la
bandera por un hecho circunstancial y
mucho mucho la matemática no era mi
fuerte y mucho menos no sabía casi
dividir pero bueno las 50 se me llevó al
estar ahí y por lo tanto sentía que el
universo me pertenecía y porque había
sido abanderado tenía que viajar y tener
una hermosa vacaciones y la verdad que
nosotros vivíamos en ese momento yo viví
en santana en el interior santana la
colonia 4 aguilar y alberdi eso era
nuestra zona de donde vivíamos en el sur
acá en la provincia de tucumán
[Música]
y dije bueno voy a soñar soñar grande en
vez de pensar en una provincia aledaña
pensé en viajar a otro país y lo primero
que pensé fue en paraguay porque
paraguay porque allí vivían y viven mi
tía hermana mi padre que yo sabía que me
iba a [ __ ] bien que me iba a recibir y
yo decía si voy a soñar porque a todo
esto acarrea mi planisferio una regla y
atrás eran diez centímetros se me
acuerdo y llegaba asunción o dije bueno
voy a viajar y llegar hasta ahora
viaje mentalmente porque no es como con
internet que uno puede viajar y recorrer
los países entonces vi el río paraguay
la ciudad las calles no sé lo soñé y
dije qué pasa si le agrego 15
centímetros más si le agrego 15
centímetros más llegó al río de janeiro
otro país bajo el carnaval playa y yo no
había salido más que lo límite entre el
río medina y río marapa que es la ciudad
dónde yo vivía y no tenía recursos bueno
después de enseñar en grande voy a
cruzar el charco y cruzar el charco
significa en europa y europa dejé
francia y francia la torre eiffel y no
sé por qué se me ocurrió eso pero dije
guau si me gustaría ir y además
significaba que tenía que aprender otro
idioma entre otras cosas y de paso ya
que estaba en europa digo voy a conocer
y yo seguía con mis reglas pensando que
la rutera recta no sé por qué se me
ocurría a mí
en mi cabeza ha pasado por eso bueno
dije voy a ir a españa voy a la roma
roma el vaticano el vaticano el papa
y yo decía tocarle al papá o verlo con
eso para mí era un sueño cumplido porque
porque yo estaba haciendo el catecismo
para hacer mi primera comunión y estaba
había venido de roma y de jerusalén la
catequista y no había comentado su
experiencia de vida y yo me transporté
con ese sueño y lo hice mío y también es
que estoy quiero conocer jerusalén
quiero estar por donde recorrió cristo
el vía crucis los golpes que él tuvo las
caídas y por qué no donde nació velen
muy próximo
a 30 km aproximadamente jerusalén y ya
que estaba porque seguía tomando mi mate
cocido con mi pan que será nuestro
desayuno habitual y muchas veces nuestra
escena estaba tomando mi último sobre de
ver si una hierba muy buena y potente
que me terminó de seña dije guau quiero
conocer también las pirámides de egipto
y quiero conocer ya que estamos la
muralla china y por este otro lado quien
no un niño quiere conocer este disney y
el caribe bien entonces que me dije en
ese momento volvió a la realidad se me
acabó el sueño y ya no tenía para salir
más allá del límite me casé del pueblo y
dije la única manera para salir
estudiando la única manera que hay mucha
otra forma pero yo entendía que la única
manera para salir de mis condición
social y poder garantizar de tener para
mí para mi futura familia poder
adquisitivo a estudiar y en ese momento
había un programa y se llamaba el chico
a la computadora y que resolvía todo y
como que me sentía identificado con eso
dije bueno hoy estudié ingeniería ese va
a ser mi profesión a eso quiero apuntar
y voy a no voy a claudicar nunca con mis
sueños para alcanzar o sea con ese
objetivo para alcanzar mi sueño
me fui a vivir a santiago el estero en
el secundario y tuve la suerte de jugar
en el seleccionado de santiago del
estero y salí campeón argentino allí
aprendí de coche o aprendí en la técnica
de trabajar en equipo ese trabajo en
equipo lo mismo que yo hago que hice en
mi vida universitaria de el que mejor
ataca el que mejor defiende que el que
más alto y etapa digamos para que no
pueda el rival hacer el doble o yo lo
fui aplicando esa misma técnica
para formar grupos de trabajo y ahí yo
bueno yo soy ingeniero en sistemas y lo
que
massa viera el área de programación y me
asocie con gente de estudiantes que
compañeros que sabía más de matemáticas
y eso me ayuda vayan a un sistema de
ayuda en recíproca porque quien no tuvo
un problema con un profesora y en parte
de clase y los demás y esa es la mejor
manera de trabajar en equipo el mismo
equipo que la misma técnica que utilizó
que conduzca una facultad al gabinete
con el cual trabajamos
y ay qué pasó yo tenía una posibilidad
otra oportunidad que no la tenía en
mente la vida deportiva profesional
estaba tenía un contrato los 16 años
para quedarme allí mis padres ya habían
venido tucumán y dije no me detengo acá
hay que aceptar significa renunciar
aceptar significa renunciar yo aceptaba
a seguir mis sueños pero tuve que
renunciar al deporte a lo que amaba que
me daba mucha felicidad porque porque
tenía un sueño más que cumplir quería
ser ingeniero y quería llegar a poder
cumplir mi sueño de ese niño de 11 años
bien finalmente he podido conocer 46
países
me recibí a todo esto y a partir de mi
profesión pude concretar muchos de mis
sueños porque porque nunca deje de soñar
siempre pensando con eso y la verdad que
tuve dificultad en mi vida universitaria
una de ellas era que llegaba cansado a
tomar clase porque porque en mi primer
trabajo en una playa de estacionamiento
me tenía que levantar a las 5 a la
mañana para estar a las 6 en el trabajo
de 6 a 7 tiene que barrer y dejar todo
limpio abrir la puerta hasta la 14 y
rogaba que el último auto se fuera a las
14 para que yo entrara a las 14 la
facultad que siempre llegaba tarde y así
se me fue demorando mi vida
universitaria y tuvo mucho traspié tal
cual como cuando ascendía la montaña y
cuando parece que llega llega a la cima
no me daba él estaba muy muy cansado y
que no tengo que llegar y voy a alcanzar
ese objetivo bien eso lo que le quiero
transmitir a los jóvenes
fundamentalmente que a todos nos da la
cabeza
que depende más de uno que el esfuerzo
vamos encontrar muchas dificultades pero
podemos seguir adelante si nos
proponemos desde llegar digamos y
alcanzar ese objetivo y no desviarnos de
nuestros sueños bien quería compartir
entonces con ustedes partes de esos
sueños este es el primer sueño que yo
tenía uno los primeros sueños grandes
soñar en grande la torre eiffel y para
eso yo había trabajado dos años fuerte
porque bueno mis padres no tenían los
recursos económicos para que yo pudiera
llegar hasta allí y poder aprender otro
idioma que yo soñaba con en ese caso
aprender el francés
quería conocer las pirámides no llegué a
las pirámides hits a veces los sueños no
se cumplen en su totalidad pero sí
estuve en medio oriente en muchos casos
por trabajo y en otro caso por turismo
acá estuve en roma y por ende llegué al
vaticano lo vi al papá bueno no este no
se me cumplió esa parte del sueño por lo
menos ese viaje
estos son los 15 centímetros que agregué
en mi inocencia para llegar que me
deparaba el destino con 15 centímetros
más desde asunción
y bueno es lo de janeiro es un sueño
nuevo que tuve en el camino y yo lo he
ido también a soñar si es que sus sueños
no se cumplen renuevan los sueños vayan
por uno nuevo porque a veces no se
cumple y si se alcanza su objetivo sus
sueños
buscan nuevos sueños para llegar para
porque es lindo estar en la vida con
nuevos sueños ese fue en rusia y en
rusia yo aprendí a destapar el tapones
auditivo y puede hablar bien el inglés y
este si es un sueño que yo lo tenía y me
entró en mi mente y me entró en un mundo
cabe en tu mente cabe en tu mundo hay
una charla te es muy interesante al
respecto que yo la hacía mí antes y
después que la vi le sugiero que la vea
eso entre mi mente y entre mi mundo yo
me había imaginado estar ahí en el muro
del lamento como me dijo la catequista
un domo de una mezquita que estaba todo
en oro y el santo sepulcro
esto ni hablar esto es en belén al final
de ese túnel es donde nació cristo el
pesebre y para lo que somos cristianos
es un momento fuerte pero cuando llegué
dije guau llegué acá otro sueño cumplido
porque porque nunca me aparté de mi
sueño quería ser ingeniero que desee
profesional porque quería vivir mejor y
entre otras cosas alcanzar este objetivo
y éste lo alcance gracias mi profesión
porque fue una misión nos llevaron en un
momento de 'break' que se les llaman y
fuimos hacer turismo ni hablar
esto es caribe y yo cuando tenía 11 años
soñaba con llegar ahí y yo lo conocía en
un río
mi hijo de 11 años en ese momento ella
estaba conociendo el caribe y se había
conocido otros países y compartí mi
sueño con mi familia y ni hablar de lo
que viene disney dios mío
yo ese día al final al finalizar el día
y me di cuenta que volvía a ser el niño
de 11 años que volvía a competir de
igual a igual con mis hijos ese día en
todos los juegos y cuando me abrace con
ello me volvía a quebrar emocionalmente
geo wow otra vez se me cumple otro sueño
gracias a que soy ingeniero gracias que
supere todas las adversidades que tuve y
nunca deje de perseguir mi sueño para
alcanzar mis objetivos
esto es una misión oficial que acompañe
a acá en el gobierno en la casa blanca
donde toman decisiones impacten todo el
mundo ni hablar es una foto icónica de
nueva york que no forma parte de mi
ensueño original pero esta y si llegue a
unas pirámides finalmente en la de
teotihuacán no la de egipto pero llegue
una pirámide y que ascenderá eso la
verdad me quedé sin aire y arriba con
mucha energía
la verdad dije wow otro sueño más
cumplido y esto sí es fantástico llegué
a la muralla china también por qué
porque forme parte de un consejo mundial
de cambio ingeniería gracias que soy
ingeniero y el evento era en beijing de
70 kilómetros está la muela china dije
no me la pierdo porque es tiempo de
cumplir mi sueño gracias mi esfuerzo
gracia el trabajo que hice para poder
llegar a alcanzar mi sueño pero todos
los sueños se cumplieron pero me faltaba
uno cuál es el sueño que me faltaba
verlo el papá tocarlo verlo de lejos y
el medio imposible y con mi esposa
estábamos tomando mate cuando cumplía
los 18 años el caso decíamos cuando
tenga buen 20 nos gustaría ir este román
renovando voto y conseguir la bendición
papal bueno finalmente nos dimos cuenta
que económicamente no podíamos porque
teníamos otro evento social los 15 de
nuestra hija y teníamos que erogar gasto
en el gasto fuerte ahí dejé bueno los
ponemos para otro momento para los 25
años dos semanas antes que cumpliéramos
años de casados me llaman del episcopado
argentino una invitación que venía del
vaticano a 70 personas
/ será yo a discutir sobre el último
encíclica papal en la 'u' datos y el
capítulo sobre educación superior
y bueno yo dije que obviamente que sí y
yo me imaginé a 4 o 5 meses y cuando
pregunté cuando me dice no nos dé a cada
semana sábado domingo lunes martes y el
miércoles el día que cumplamos
aniversario los 20 años casado era el
día que uno de esos 70 persona iba a
estar con el papá entregando el
documento y demás dije bueno nada
ese sueño se terminó concretando pudimos
ir acepté esa invitación obviamente no
le iba a desaprovechar le invite a mi
esposa y nos fuimos y tuvimos con el
papel yo decía que le puede entregar
desde presente a una persona que lo
tiene todo y no le hace falta nada y yo
había escuchado cómo había pasado por la
rioja que le había llamado a una radio
de allí a en una entrevista dijo que le
gustaba la grapa y la grapa de ese
pueblito de pituil entonces cuando lo
vea santo padre- que venía muy cansado
apesumbrado deje su santo padre le
traigo un pequeño presente muchas
gracias por haberme invitado por estar
acá es un sueño para mí cumplido y le
quiero entregar este humilde presente
grapa grapa necesite pituil de pituil no
se imaginan la felicidad del papel y lo
feliz que me hizo saber que algo les
gustaba tanto y que yo lo estaba
haciendo feliz y a la vez le dije del
santo padre acá vamos a cumplir nosotros
en los
20 años casados y también nos dio la
bendición papal esa es la parte que no
se ve del esfuerzo y la cultura que uno
tiene tener el trabajo para llegar al
sueño que al comienzo parecen imposibles
un niño de 11 años sentado pensando en
viajar y que luego eso improbable porque
no tiene dinero no hay forma pero se
compromete con su sueño y un sueño era a
través de estudiar ingeniería cuando eso
sueño uno se compromete se vuelven
inevitables este mi familia a la cual
fue un sueño más de lo que yo tuve de
conformar una familia y puede darle
brindarle todas las comodidades hoy tuve
la suerte de contar en mi camino de ser
ingeniero
un camino que empezó en el sueño de un
niño en la duda de un adolescente
en el esfuerzo de un adulto en el dolor
y la alegría de la pobreza en el
sacrificio de mis padres y la suerte se
emitía un camino que ya no lo camino
solo un camino que los caminos junto a
mi esposa mis hijos en el sueño de mis
padres de mis amigos de mis colegas y mi
familia un camino que ya no sé a dónde
llegar a hablar con usted y aquí ha sido
otro sueño cumplido una parte más de mi
camino los animó a soñar y encontrar su
camino hola soy fabián un tipo feliz que
eligió el camino a ser ingeniero
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]